loved his work back in the day in Oz law
and order and now in the new film the
front-runner in which he plays the
campaign manager - Hugh Jackman's Gary
Hart it opens up Wednesday before
Thanksgiving good to see you JK Simmons
and do you richard eyes right back at
you man all right do we talk about the
elephant in the room or do we talk about
the mini helmet in the room well I mean
you know that many helmets always there
it's the Michigan helmet and again by
the way my all my OSU buddies and I'm
just one of our nicknames for your team
besides tea um yes the school up north
yeah right team up north right stupid
helmets stupid helmets yeah I mean what
is that is that a wolf does that somehow
represent a wolverine well you know I I
think it's a thing of beauty I think it
is something that speaks to class
elegance and also a winning tradition is
what that looks like we could go back
and forth I mean what the hell is a
Buckeye all right okay is a poisonous
nut I think he looks like a freak dork
stud
all right so how how where are you on a
level of 1 to 10
concerned and so I'm concerned yeah I
mean always always always concerned you
know and more concerned when we're a
favorite which apparently we are I don't
understand mean you know where it's you
know another week away we have to
trounce Maryland first and I forget what
a hapless team you guys Indiana Indiana
they can move the ball they can I know
that's one of those thing in some
Michigan home game you know you never
know when you've got 18 to 21 year olds
look although your defense a yeah look I
think I think we'll be fine we'll beat
we'll be facing each other with one loss
each and
yeah I honestly think this this is the
year that you guys take out I two
decades of frustration excuse me excuse
me it's not two decades it's not it's
it's not okay so starting with Russell
right and and the you know and then then
the one interim year doesn't count and
then okay oh the urban here the the one
you're pretty fun for quite a while I
know it has and that's why I don't want
to hear it from people who are like this
this year because I just know whatever
is ailing the offense and there's a lot
and whatever is ailing the front seven
or the linebackers or the back seven
let's put the back seven alright that's
gonna magically go away well off noon
eastern on the Saturday after
Thanksgiving you could argue that
Michigan State had a pretty hapless
offense but I mean that's that's the
best our defenses looked all year I
think our linebackers look like Ohio
State linebackers really kind of for the
first time all year yeah it's amazing I
think what's happened if we can have
like a serious nonpartisan even though
that has nothing to debts and nothing to
do with the frontrunner conversation but
to me to me it seems that Nick Bose is
saying I'm not coming back was something
that affected and I'm not saying this
just to troll I really believe it
affected Ohio State this year yeah I
think I mean the injury you know yeah I
mean he's arguably the best player in
college football he's gonna be the
number one overall pick in the NFL Draft
you would think I think that's exactly
who the Raiders are tanking for right
now quite honestly yeah I really believe
it oh man it'll be a Raider I mean
that's basically the the NFL teams as
you know I basically root for NFL teams
based on how many Buckeyes they have
right I'm a big New Orleans fan right
now and the Los Angeles chargers with
Joey Bosa comes back yeah but no New
Orleans that the other the entire
secondaries alive yeah yeah and Michael
Thomas the best receiver in football I
mean
ridiculous you can't make that argument
but but Nick Bose is saying I'm not
coming back I think a little bit of what
I mean you know you can't really argue
with that choice I mean I mean he could
have come back probably for you know the
game but but you know he's got a lot on
the line
JK Simmons here in the Rich Eisen show
do you think this is Urban's last year
there's a lot of talk about that there's
a ton of chatter yeah I don't know I I
have no idea but just your gut feeling
no I don't know I don't know either I
mean nobody knows but there's just I
don't think so I think we can be so good
next year you know I mean we're losing a
lot of great receivers and 60% of the
o-line but but we're basically a really
young team I feel like going into this
year I felt like we were a year away
from from winning a competing for a
national championship so I would I would
for a number of reasons I would be
surprised if he walked away now and I
hope he doesn't so again you're you're
Ohio State love just to repeat because
you've said it before you're on the show
and just in case there's anybody new
watching this comes from your dad taught
at the school right is that true my dad
taught there he took a job there we left
Detroit for Columbus Ohio when I was 10
years old so all during my junior high
and high school years my dad was on the
faculty at Ohio State and I got to go to
the games and like the 68 national
championship team I was 13 mm-hmm you
know went to the game against Purdue and
Leroy Keys yeah and yeah that was 68 was
a great year for me because I just moved
from Detroit and the Tigers won you know
the World Series that year in the
Buckeyes were the national champs and to
this day you still have your tiger and
those are my guy my two guys over I
don't know you're the only one I know I
don't know anybody I've many ways I know
you are very unique in many ways
yeah well let's put this way you're
definitely probably the only one the
only Tiger / Buckeyes slash Academy
Award winner I'll I'll probably ever
meet that's a reasonably safe bet
like that so so in that regard
what are you how have you been watching
Verlander succeed as well as he is for
the Astro side you're making a face
right here line up for the radio on it
so I'll describe it but has it been
tough for you to see that
yes and no I mean he's one of the guys
that I that I you know now that I'm all
famous and stuff I get to go you know
down in the field and meet the guys
before the games and stuff and and he's
a guy that you know that I clicked with
and we we have stayed in contact and the
day that he made that you know 11:59 and
59 seconds p.m. decision we were texting
that day I was in Detroit and we were
gonna have lunch two days later in
Detroit and he was as we all know in on
a plane to Houston he was that I know
he's been tremendous well he's I mean
look he was tremendous in Detroit I mean
I mean he he had some you know he didn't
win as many games you know that last
year-and-a-half in Detroit but he was
you know fighting through some injuries
and and has always been as a good a
pitcher as he's been for the last year
and a half with Houston it's just he's
gotten the results and and you know he's
got a team scoring run for and the ring
I mean he's got that runner ring he
that's good a just had a kid too yeah
had a careful think he just had a little
baby daughter such a beautiful thing but
I know right
so did you order lunch ever get
rescheduled ever get no we haven't got
together in person since that night yeah
I know
I mean you're busy man do you had lots
going on yeah and he's wearing just a
weird hat with a star on it now I mean I
you know it's weird I mean honestly and
I know this is hopelessly old-fashioned
but you know at this point with free
agency in in in every sport and with you
know College sophomores going off to the
pros like you're basically rooting for a
logo at this point because there's no
loyalty and there's no Cal Ripken's
there's no Kirby Puckett's you know who
are gonna be with their teams for you
know I mean Alan Trammell you know is
you know those guys are right start to
finish you know that's what Seinfeld
Joey's jokes that you root for laundry
laundry that was that was one of his
stand up as you root for laundry you
don't root for the guys
you root for the laundry the true fact
because that's you know that it's
amazing how things change and how
quickly they can change let's talk about
your new film here JK Simmons the
front-runner it's the story about Gary
Hart's presidential campaign in 1988
going down the tubes fast with him being
the front-runner it looked like he was
definitely going to take on poppy bush
in that election and for those who may
not remember a scandal of him cheating
on his wife came out Donna rice being
the one who was in front and center in
this whole film is about that moment you
play the campaign manager in this what
did you what did you take out of this
experience this film from 1988 now in
2018
well I there's a few elements of this
film that first of all Hugh Jackman by
the way is is one of those guys I mean
he's one of the biggest movie stars on
the planet but he's like he's like drew
brees right but he acts like you know
the second-string left guard he's just
one of the guys just just uh just a
principal fella just thought I'd throw
that out no but he's it sees absurdly
talented I mean my very talented and
also like a brick poop house he's one of
those guys who you slap him on the
shoulder when you see him and you go oh
yeah well I mean solid and in my house
the greatest showman we've seen that
movie about a million oh sure oh yeah
yeah
well might then my daughter we just my
daughter just had her High School
Musical this past weekend so you know
she's a big fan on on that level as well
right and he plays Gary Hart in this
film he's terrific and doesn't great and
he any really channels Gary Hart
brilliantly apparently he was Australian
yeah he and and Veera who plays severe
farming who plays his wife Lee really
recreate that and and those are you know
iconic moments and iconic people that
guys my age remember very well so that
to me is always a very intimidating task
my character is not a guy who was in the
public eye is very much behind the
scenes Bill Dixon and in fact I looked
not remotely like him i but but jason
reitman our wonderful writer director
really was only concerned with having
Gary and Lee Hart and Donna rice you
know be be a somewhat recognizable as as
the real people they were playing and
it's 30 years ago it's amazing just
watching it about how that was new
that's a scandal of that nature could
actually be injected into a political
conversation and Gary Hart just refused
to accept the reality that it could be
and we all know what happened well yeah
because because history you know was on
his side really I mean it had been
pretty much nudge-nudge wink-wink before
you know all through I mean I don't know
about how many American presidents but
there are several that we know of
you know before 1987 who you know just
routinely had mistresses on the side and
you know ladies coming and going and the
press just turned a blind eye that was
just the way it was so it's again you're
great and everything the missus is no
exception this is really terrific people
should see it again it starts Wednesday
before Thanksgiving counterpart as well
second season coming back on Starz in
December congratulations on that
yeah thanks last time you were on is
when you were promoting that series for
the first time the first time around
yeah all right and so what can fans of
that show expect in season 2 more
complexity more intrigue more new
characters baby Gabriel joins the cast
and James Cromwell some some great new
characters in addition to all the the
characters that they've come to know and
love and or hate okay and that's gonna
be in stars coming on December 9th is
the second season for that and you're
you just told me Brockman oh he just
dropped on me as he sat down fresh off
of a cameo appearance shot for the new
season of Brock Meyer Brock Meyer with
with the brilliant Hank Azaria as for
those people those few sports fans who
don't know
playing Jim Brock Meyer the
baseball broadcaster and it's it the
show is just what do you play and then I
play Matt the bat Hardesty an ex-player
baseball announcer and his nickname has
nothing to do with his hitting prowess
and Costas is on typecast again was Bob
- Bob Costas I got - I pretended that I
needed to go to set on the day that Bob
and I were both there just because I
wanted to jump into the van and have you
know five minutes of it laughs yeah
where I basically kidnapped Bob and well
I bet you did I mean it was he who was
hitting his his makeup for for a
flashback scene well yeah so it was Bob
Costas you know with looking like Bob
Costas 25 years ago okay which is
frankly not that different even button
yeah yeah and so you could have really
gone down Tigers memory lane with him
there I bet you did right yeah sure yeah
of course he probably knew he probably
knew like mcdhh any McLane's back of his
baseball card and willie horton and all
those guys at the top of his dome
yeah he's an encyclopedia all right
before I let you go we play a game
called start bench cut here on the
program since you've been here left so
you need to you need to it you need to
choose one to start one to bench one to
cut
okay we've put gonna put you in a little
bit of a spot here let's play here we go
start bench cut you have to choose one
you have to bench when you have to cut
one best Buckeye in the National
Football League right now Zeke the
aforementioned Michael Thomas or Joey
Bosa Wow
start bench cut yeah that's how we roll
here one of them it's done bench cut
start [ __ ] cut well I guess I'll cut
Joey Bosa just because he's coming off
an injury anything I mean that's a rough
wait I mean often tumble and if the
world I understand so hard when you
start and you
bench well well bench doesn't mean they
have to sit the whole game but you give
this but you must start only one well
I'm gonna start Michael Thomas and then
lazy can sit down for the first series
and I'd almost come in and have much
legs Michael Thomas he's still really
Amelie he's unbelievable and the
aforementioned breeze that you mentioned
he said we were talking about it
Brees is the most accurate passer in the
history NFL throwing to a guy who
catches everything everything his
catcher it's 90 percent yeah and he's
got a quarterback who throws it on
target 90% of the time so basically the
catch is everything pretty good next one
up best former Tiger pitcher no longer
on the team bench Verlander Scherzer and
current World Series champion suddenly
where did he come from right horse cell
oh yeah dude and and you could add David
Price I mean the list goes on okay these
are the three weeks you start all right
I start bench cut
I'm gonna cut Porcello just cuz he's
from Jersey I'm gonna start JV just cuz
he's a pal and benchers and I'm gonna
bench as Max Scherzer is not that good
in the game it's not your it's not it's
not you it's us alright next one here
we've cut Schillinger out and you'll
understand later Hillinger pardon me
you've cut Schilling out my bad oh I
shouldn't he just went shilling her
under that character woman okay so the
most unlikable character you've
portrayed okay Jay jonah Jameson BR and
thank you for smoking or Terrence
Fletcher in whiplash most unlikable
character that you've played in film
well I see why feeling it was cut
because he's the only one of those who
was an actual you know rapist and
murderer at once yes an overt racist
well I I guess so the least likable
would be the one I start that's it yes
that's it well I'm gonna have to start
Fletcher because he hates everybody I'm
gonna I'm gonna bench BR and I'm gonna
I'm gonna cut Jay jonah Jameson I
thought he was just charming as hell
actually I gotta be honest with you
though in if watching whiplash as much
as I hated him just hated him and wanted
him to get it come up and I wanted I
wanted him to turn I wanted I was just
rooting the entire time for something
good to come out of you
dude that's that the the brilliance of
Damien Chazelle and that and that whole
story yeah I love that movie I mean and
and the the that ambiguity you know is
what you know along with Damien and
miles teller and you know it's what made
it just as great isn't right I mean I
always was just as much as I'm like I
went back and forth like man I wanted
you to eat it
I wanted you to eat it but I want to do
with like a buck I wore anything just no
no that only added to it but I just
wanted that I just wanted some
Redemption some redemptive quality to
come why why do you think that is that's
because I'm just such a likeable here
very good great to see you JK so great
to see you
check check out the front runner in
theaters near you Wednesday November
21st and then keep an eye peeled for
counterpart to return to Stars season to
December 9th and of course Brock Meyer
down the line great to see you sir you
do back with more in a moment the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience